être variés anglais sud africain ou
encore brésilien la mutation du
coronavirus fait repartir les
contaminations à la hausse et inquiète
les modernes a failli thebeau ntech et
astrazeneca de ce monde seront ils tout
aussi efficace contre les mutations
actuelles et futures du sascoc deux
peut-être pas quand les laboratoires de
cette petite firme de biotech de lyon ce
n'est pas tout à fait la question qui
intéresse ici la course au vaccin c'est
celle d'un vaccin universel contre
toutes les formes de coronavirus notre
concept initial n'était pas de se
préparer pour ces variants parce que
quand on a commencé à travailler sur ce
sur ce projet l'année dernière les
variants n'avait pas encore émergé
nous notre concept c'était d'avoir un
vaccin qui pourrait protéger contre une
future épidémie de coronavirus il faut
savoir qu'il y en a déjà eu plusieurs
il ya eu le cers covéa il ya eu le maire
ce maintenance harsco v2 les variants
mais n'était pas arrivé l'année dernière
et peut-être une future épidémie avec un
autre coronavirus les vaccins actuels
cherche à déclencher une réponse
d'anticorps en ciblant la surface du
virus
la fameuse protéine spike c'est cette
même protéine que l'on voit actuellement
muté pour donner les nouveaux variants
le vaccin que développe aux ivax lui
vise le coeur du virus la nucléocapside
l'avantagent cette partie du virus est
beaucoup moins sujet aux mutations que
la surface extérieure
ici ce sont des vial de vaccin grippe
aux ivax n'est pas parti de rien pour
élaborer son vaccin contre la copie
depuis 2014
les chercheurs à l'origine de
l'entreprise innovante planche sur un
vaccin universel contre la grippe qui
s'appuie sur le même principe
les virus de grippe ils mutent en
permanence c'est à dire qu'à chaque
saison l'om est prédit les souches qui
vont circuler à la saison prochaine est
inclus dans les vaccins de la saison
hivernale les virus dont ils penseront
circule donc chaque année le la
composition du vaccin grippe est adaptée
et malgré les gros efforts pour adapter
les souches d'e fois la préparation et
protectrice disons à 60 70 % et des fois
on a mal ciblé les souches est donc là
le l'efficacité du vaccin peut diminuer
jusqu'à 20%
tu travailles sur le vaccin gay pour le
vaccin covit d'un flash sur leur écran
cosy mozzy valls a déjà produit une
version du 25 au vide qui s'est avérée
efficace sur les animaux et espère
pouvoir lancer des études cliniques chez
l'humain
d'ici la fin de l'année entre temps la
formulation continue d'être testé pour
s'assurer de sa pureté et de la
stabilité du produit
on va en faire jusqu'à ce qu'on soit
content du procès des purifications à
savoir qu' il faut que le procédé de
purification donne le produit de la
bonne qualité et aussi que l'on puisse
ensuite mettre le procédé à l échelle
parce que la haute au niveau du
laboratoire on va travailler sur
quelques dizaines
mg de produits mais après quand on
voudra a développé le process à grande
échelle il faut que ce procédé soit
applicable à pour des millions de doses
la petite équipe de ivax a reçu 15
millions d'euros de la banque publique
d'investissement de la france est
l'équivalent du conseil européen pour
l'innovation
ce sont 46 millions de dollars qui sont
les bienvenus mais histoire de donner un
peu de perspective c'est loin très loin
et deux milliards et demi octroyées par
les états unis a father avant même que
son vaccin ne soit prêt ici marie-eve
bédard radio-canada lyon